khi học thử chiến, cuối hội khoả mười lắm đã biểu quyết thương qua lột thử thử thủ đặc biệt,
sữa đổi. Chúng đó, bộ dùng điều hoàn yên độ công sất lớn vào diễn triệu thủy.
Theo đó, điều hoàn yên độ có công sức trên 2 mết tư nghìn bê tế uống đến chi Minh yên bê tế uống thuộc
bởi tự sự thủy thủy thủy thủy thủy đều hoàn yên độ có công sất từ 2 mết tư nghìn bê tế uống
vật lại có công sức trên chi Minh yên bê tế uống. A dụ từ ngày 1,5 năm 2020, chính sách này đã tình đến yếu tốt công bằng sảo,
không đánh thử tranh laan lên các sản phẩm phổ biến đang được sự dụng giống giống giống các hộ ra đình có thu nhập trù mình.
Chánh kê anh vừa đến hoàn động sản xuất, kinh xanh quy mối lấn.
Vy tăng thử thủ đặc biệt nhằm đều tiết hành video dùng, khuyến khích xanh nghiệp sản xuất các thiết bị tiếp kiện định,
ít gây tắc hại với tận uống.
Chinh thế giới, nhiều cuốc gia đã thủ thủy với mặt hàng đều hoàn yên hành quốc,
ấn độ, nởi hài các nước trường ông cũng đã có chính sách từ tự.
Dù đừng đánh giá là bước đi đúng hướng trong một tiêu phát triển kinh tế xanh,
các chuyên gia cho rằng cần có cơ trề yêu đại só giảng cho thiết bị tiếp kiện năng lực.
Nguyên dân cũng bài tỏ mông muốn chính sách phần lại chi tiết hơn,
không đánh đồng sản phẩm tiếp kiện định với thiết bị lạc hộ.
Đông thời phy nghĩ nhảnh nước hỗ trợ tại chính đề chuyển đổi xác thiết bị xanh.